i would like
if i may
to take you
on a strange journey
[Music]
hello there folks we are going to be
dipping into
a very complicated topic today and uh
props to anybody who caught the
reference that i used in the opening gag
and even those of you who didn't don't
worry i'll actually be circling back
onto the film that was pulled from at a
later point in the video so stick around
find out what it was if you didn't
already know today
we're going to talk about
consent
specifically depictions of consent
in popular media more specifically
the
dearth and lack
of depictions of consent
in mainstream media
this is
a difficult topic for a lot of reasons
it obviously by necessity is going to
dip into some areas that may make some
people uncomfortable to talk about
i'm going to try and avoid talking about
them in such a way that would be
outright triggering but if the topic in
general of consent or a lack of consent
is concerning to you it's okay to skip
this video but before you make the
decision to do that i want to be clear
on what i'm talking about here
i'm not going to be going through
various instances in various films or tv
or whatever where something that is flat
out sexual assault is treated as not a
big deal
that's the kind of thing you find in a
lot of
80s movies don't ever re-watch revenge
of the nerds if you ever did and if you
haven't seen it don't but we're not
talking about that kind of thing we're
not talking about a case of something
that was clearly not okay but was
treated as okay instead i want to deal
with just the fact that consent at all
like just pausing before the start of
engaging in things and going hey
are you okay with this
is it okay if we take it to this step
just doesn't happen
now i am going to be talking about some
of the more gray area instances but the
actual worst examples we're largely not
going to be touching here except just to
acknowledge that yeah that's how badly
it can go but that's not where i'm
dwelling for this so by and large this
is more about the lack
of addressing consent and this is by
necessity going to become also a bigger
discussion of the fact that consent is
uh
is an odd thing
in the current discourse
because it's something that
should be very standard it should be
deeply uncontroversial
to attain consent
however it's something that gets a lot
of pushback
from people who either
don't think very hard about why they're
pushing back on it
or know exactly why they're pushing back
on it you get people who slam the idea
of asking for consent you get everything
from well it's not romantic it kills the
mood to this general idea of well i
don't know what is or isn't okay anymore
well you know how you'd know
if you asked for consent
but i'm dealing more with that first
issue where people are like well it's
it's unromantic it breaks the mood how
is that like sexy and
that's an issue that we can kind of lay
on the feet of popular culture
because
in popular culture
we haven't really done a good job in
depicting consent as a normal part of
intimate relations with people most
films and movies
just don't show it
sometimes you can head canon that there
was a can a consent conversation that
was had because there's often a time
jump ahead you know from the first kiss
to they're getting in the bed you could
head cannon that a consent conversation
happened but it doesn't get shown
almost ever
and
that's
kind of part of the problem not the only
part of the problem but part of the
problem because
since we've left it out of our popular
culture
we think of it as an intrusion
onto something romantic and since so
much of our perception of romance is
shaped yes by our immediate surroundings
and the people around us but also by
the pop culture that we absorb the fact
that it's not there
does not help and it makes
things worse now in terms of how things
got the way they are it's worth
indulging at least a little bit in the
historical perspective which is that you
go back to films from the golden age of
hollywood and part of the reason you
wouldn't get discussions of consent is
to properly handle consent
often means properly acknowledging
sex
because
it was one thing back in the day of say
the haze code for the hero and the
heroine to kiss and then you pan the
camera over to some wind blowing the
curtains and you imply what's going on
but when they actually pause and stop
and talk about it well if you're not in
playing anymore you're saying it
outright and now you're
you're catching the ire of people who
don't want you to talk about it
so
that's part of how things kind of
initially were off on the wrong foot
from the early point of these things and
there are
more than enough um
classic movies you can see where
you d you dip into
let's go with
a little bit of a divergence into the
topic of
dubious
consent
so
this uh in terms of like films would be
where
a male character is initially
clearly the sexual aggressor in a scene
a modern instance from a film that i
love
but this scene is a problem
is the film blade runner where you have
our lead hero
stop
the female love interest from leaving
and push her back
and
not quite force himself on her but
pretty close
now she does eventually say
kiss me but that's only after he
prompted her to do so
kiss me
[Music]
so i don't want to dig too much into the
scene into why it's problematic but it
is illustrative in that it starts this
way but then every time we see them
together subsequent it seems to be
genuine and affectionate
so this is the kind of thing that you
actually would get a fair amount in
terms of dealing with
manly men
dominant men
and the issue of dominant men
controlling women that goes way back
before hollywood you can go back to
shakespeare and see some issues with
that with things like taming of the
shrew which is a fantastic play right up
until the very end when suddenly it very
much is not
come
and place your hands below your
husband's foot in token of which duty if
he please
my hand is ready but it's worth
diverging at least briefly on the
general topic of
dubious consent or
what is termed in
uh kink circles as consensual
non-consent just because i want to
be clear that
these are kind of separate things from
what we're talking about but i also want
to explain them because i've seen a lot
of bleed over and misunderstanding so
consensual non-consent is actually
something that i've seen depicted
incredibly rarely in film and television
but is an actual real-life practice
so part of the reason i want to talk
about this is because it is worth
acknowledging that for some people a
more dubious consent is actually
enticing not just as a matter of it's
what you're used to you actually take
enjoyment from it in a consensual
non-consent scene you will have the two
people participating in it and the
scene itself will play out as if one of
them is not consenting to what's going
on but the important thing in those
scenes
um and that that's uh the
term in king circles for when two people
engage in
uh a role play or other kinds of
activities like that so don't be
confused when i say scene because we're
also gonna be talking about movie scenes
later but
anyways prior to the start of that scene
the two of them have very thoroughly
consented
to entering into a scene that will play
as if
there is no consent and also properly
done there is always a safe word and the
scene can be ended at any point by
either person involved
that's not something you see depicted
very much but again i think it's worth
noting because there is actually an
appeal to a lack of consent for some
people and pretending that nobody likes
that
isn't
productive what's interesting about
cases of dubious consent is that
i'm not going to say they're necessarily
more common in literature well at this
point they might be i'm not going to say
that's the case traditionally because
like i said plenty of classic hollywood
movies and even some relatively recent
ones have issues of
a man
putting himself kind of aggressively
towards a woman who then
starts to like it even though she didn't
initially goldfinger another
classic instance of that
the thing is i think that's something
that if you're going to do it it works
much much better in print than on film
largely because
when you read a book
most things that dip into this
are written from the perspective of
the female in those scenes because near
basically every dubious consent scene is
a aggressive man and uh and a woman who
initially you're like is she okay with
this and then it's clear that she is
later on
so in literature you can get away with
it more because
these scenes are almost always from the
perspective of the woman involved not
necessarily first person but like we get
her thoughts and so
the
author is able to bring the audiences
and assure them that she was a little
unsure at first but it can let them know
how quickly
she has become okay with this
whereas to take an example that was
badly botched and again try not to dwell
on it too much
season four i believe it was of game of
thrones rather infamous scene between
the incestuous siblings cersei and jaime
lannister
i'm not going to get into the full
details of the scene but basically there
was a massive
debate and a bit of an outcry after this
scene aired because
it looked like he was proceeding forward
when she was saying no now the creators
said afterwards that that wasn't their
intent and they wanted something more
ambiguous and i'm actually while i don't
have a lot of respect for them as
writers i don't think they're very good
especially with how that show ended but
i do think they're being honest about
that i think they thought they were
doing something
a bit gray area but the thing is we
don't know her thoughts
we don't know at what point if at any
she became okay with this whereas in
print
it would be possible for the audience to
know that much much much sooner and so
that it
takes not the entire curse off because
again people will have their own uh
levels that they're okay with dealing
with uh dubious consent but at the very
least it has the potential to reassure
audiences way earlier whereas when we
don't have access to the thoughts of the
characters
well we don't know and part of the other
reason i wanted to bring up dubious
consent is it brings in something that
is an easy trap for
any creator writer director etc to fall
into
which is that
if the writer already knows
that the person who initially doesn't
appear to be consenting is ultimately
going to be okay with it
it becomes easy to forget
the audience doesn't know that in
advance
so
it's easy for writers to often
accidentally
overlook the fact that consent is not
being properly
handled and understand consent is not
simply asking
you know are you okay if we do this it's
also about being informed this is
something that the uh 50 shades of grey
books and movies are terrible at because
christian is frequently
setting up scenarios and bringing out
toys and not properly explaining their
use to anastasia before implementing
them if those conversations happen at
all we are not privy to them and so
there is a lack of conformed of informed
consent even if she says yes she's doing
it on blind faith which that's not
properly informed consent but it happens
anyways because the original author and
then the filmmakers already know she's
going to be into it once it starts
so it becomes easy to think oh it's okay
that she's not properly informed because
she's going to like it anyway but you
only know that on a meta level as the
writer or as if you were on a
re-watch the actual facts of the scene
simply fail to deal with proper informed
consent of what's about to happen
and that
is kind of a problem again i don't want
to overshame the notion of the lack of
consent and i certainly don't want to
shame anyone who is into issues of or
scenes of dubious consent or consensual
non-consent
let me be very clear about that
however
these things do get intertwined and
intermixed and the way that some of
these things get addressed or don't get
addressed that is a bit more acceptable
in
certain media or certain genres certain
conventions
the general
lack of acknowledgement
of consent
i just don't think is healthy
i think
consent
should be the standard it should be the
default in any given scene that the
characters both establish what it is
that they are and aro are not okay with
going forward that should be the
standard not the exception and the
dubious consent or the non-consent
scenes those should be the exception i'm
not saying we can't have them but they
shouldn't be the norm
could you grant me that at least now
there's some general tropes and things
that tend to play into and lead to
a lack of consent and some of these
things i think hopefully people are
starting to realize aren't
the best in the world i mentioned
dominant men already the idea that a man
has to take a woman control
a woman and again while i'm not gonna
say that's never okay to depict it has
been the default for a very
very
very
long time and
it hasn't gotten much better and the
pace of which it has has been real real
slow
another aspect of that is the whole
notion
of a woman playing hard to get all right
i'm sorry though i'm going to the game
with somebody else
not anymore besides what you think you
left your purse at my place by accident
no subconsciously you are dying to take
me to that game
i haven't seen this general idea
challenged
as broadly as i would like it to
because while i'm not going to say that
there is no such thing as playing hard
to get and that nobody ever does it
because that would be foolish of me to
claim
it's prominence as a depiction to the
phrase that just me saying playing hard
to get you know what that phrase means
maybe it shouldn't be that ubiquitous
because
if you were to
not only watch a movie but extrapolate
things you've seen into a movie into
your real-life understanding of social
cues because
i'm not saying that people behave
exactly like they see in movies but
things that are normalized in movies
generally tend to become normalized in
reality as well
so
can you really
distinctly
tell the difference
between a person
who is not interested
or who's just playing hard to get
and again not to say there is no such
thing as playing hard to get
but since consent is not standard in
depiction
there isn't really a lot of difference
until it gets pushed so far that i don't
know she throws a drink in his face and
even then
depending on the genre about half the
time they're gonna end up getting
together anyways which is another aspect
i suppose the hostility to lovers thing
now in more extreme cases you get like
uh enemies to lovers like an anime and i
feel like those sorts of situations are
often heightened enough by bizarre
circumstances fantasy scenarios etc that
i'm not going to dwell on that too much
however in rom-coms set in the real
world ostensibly showing real people
the degree to which
outright hostility
to eventual lovers is standard operating
procedure
i find that worrying
and i get why it's there if you're
having a romance story
and you eventually intend for these two
to get together well you can't just
start they're instantly into each other
well you can but then usually you have
to introduce a massive logistical hurdle
a la romeo and juliet or something else
of that nature but if you're not going
to introduce a massive logistical hurdle
and you want the story to instead be
about the way these two come to care
about each other well the easiest way to
have an arc of the relationship is to
have them initially not liking each
other and then eventually liking each
other so conceptually on paper i get it
but
it's been taken to an extreme in a lot
of cases it's not just a matter of i
don't click with that person
it's frighteningly common
in
romances especially romantic comedies
for the two people who all eventually
end up together
to hate each other and again this idea
of
well
yeah
they don't like me
but they will eventually
and again i think the ramping up of how
severe that initial hatred can be
sometimes
is a trap that writers fall into because
they know they're going to end up
together by the end anyway so i mean
like what's it matter how much they hate
each other at the start well
when you're hammering home
the idea over and over and over again
that
initial rejection i want you i need you
oh baby oh baby
or dislike
if i really knew you i know what i would
find instead of a brain a cash register
instead of a heart a bottom line
or even hatred you sam alone are the
most arrogant self-centered son
does not actually preclude these people
from getting together
i hate you are you as turned on as i am
more
what are the takeaway messages
for people
taking in this entertainment
what behavior
are you normalizing
when a rejection is not taken
as a reason to stop
where hostility is not taken as a reason
to not eventually end up as sexual
partners
that again
i find a bit concerning
and like i said this stuff is all over
the place
it's in some of my favorite movies i
mentioned blade runner and if you
remember the movie that i referenced at
the very start rocky horror picture show
which i love like that movie means so
much to me i did a whole video on why
that movie means so much to me and so
much to so many people
however
it absolutely has multiple scenes
of the character frank
basically forcing himself
onto people
until they like it
and the character of rocky exists at all
to be frank's plaything
and has no say in the matter
now
arguably frank's actually the villain of
the film so i you can make an argument
that it's not necessarily glorifying
that but there also isn't much in the
way of counterbalancing
in terms of saying well he's the bad guy
here's how the good guys do it
especially with the impact this has on
brad and janet
so
seeing this so
prevalent
and rooted in again
media that i love and i'm not gonna stop
watching
but i also know people
who i would not recommend these movies
to or who have told me that they hate
these movies because of this kind of
material
and i don't blame them one single bit
but two something that i mentioned
earlier
the idea that
look we can't stop and ask for
permission at all these stages like
consent isn't sexy consent breaks up the
flow
are you sure about that
because first of all you know you say
that for a movie if you can't even
handle
30 seconds to address consent in a movie
how are you dealing with it in real life
so there's that and let's also keep in
mind that historically you go back far
enough
uh there used to be a time where guys
would argue that
putting out a condom
wasn't romantic
and interrupted the flow
which is actually also something that
movies are really really bad about
depicting uh safe sex they almost never
um take the time to make it clear when a
condom or any other
safe sex uh product or device is being
used
and generally as i said before jump from
the kiss to them in bed we have no idea
you could head cannon they're having
protected sex but they won't show it
i'm not going to go too far off the
rails on that because honestly it's kind
of the same deal as it is with consent
they could normalize it it could just be
just a simple thing of reaching for the
condom that's all it would really take
and most movies don't do it
here's the thing i debated like how many
examples do i want to give of movies tv
etc that have done consent well and i
think increasingly you're seeing it
better done but it's often
a bit like the video i did last week
talking about representation it's a bit
more relegated to niche media
in things aimed at a smaller more
targeted audience
you will see this start to come up more
and more often in either movies made for
streaming services or series that aren't
necessarily being viewed by the masses
by the mainstream
and i could cite you a ton of those
examples but most people probably
wouldn't know them and i'd have to show
clips i'd risk copyright all this stuff
but you know what
i don't have to reference
small
independent
niche
micro targeted media for an excellent
example of consent
i can cite
one of the
highest grossing
most viewed most awarded films ever made
my friends
let's talk about consent
in the film
titanic
yeah
titanic james cameron leonardo dicaprio
kate winslet
that titanic
because it handles consent
really
really well
so there's two primary scenes that i
want to draw attention to
one is the scene where jack draws rose
the other
is what happens when they're in the car
so
in both cases they're already counter
balancing the typical narrative of the
man initiating everything because women
initiating things women being the more
dominant in a
sexual scene
is usually reserved
for
femme fatales
villainesses
women that the movie is otherwise
judging as being
loose and easy
that's not the case here
every step that these two move
towards physical intimacy
is initiated
by rose
jack i want you to draw me like one of
your french girls
wearing this it is her idea
for him to draw her
wearing only this
it is her idea
for him to draw her naked
she does know that he draws people naked
that this is not something outside of
his usual comfort zone
and she does give him the heads up
saying i want you to draw me in this
wearing only this
she doesn't shock him she doesn't come
out in the robe and suddenly she's naked
and he didn't expect that he knew it was
going to happen he's still a little
surprised because kate winslet in
the late 90s she's gorgeous but he knew
he knew and he had set up and he was
ready to draw her knowing she was not
going to be clothed
she proposed it
he agreed to it
that's the first thing
then
we have their actual sex scene in the
car
and again initiated by her
she pulls him back into the back seat
jack honestly
he's a bit of a soft boy in this
and she stops before things start really
going and she says to him
put your hands on me jack
she says what she wants
and waits for him
to acknowledge he is also okay with that
by moving forward
all of this
is integrated into the flow of
conversation of interaction
it never feels like it stops the scene
it's baked into the scene and it's best
known as a romance
so don't ever
ever try to tell me that asking for
consent
isn't
sexy
because
jack and rose would like a word
and honestly
that's what i want to see more of
i don't need you to literally stop the
scene dead for them to sit down and
negotiate what they are and aren't going
to do and the fact that people so many
think that's what consent would look
like in order to have it in films shows
how much more we need to depict it
because i've just given you an example
where it is seamlessly integrated to the
point that i bet a whole bunch of you
didn't even realize that consent was a
core part of those scenes
this is what we need
it's not that hard
it's not that jarring
it doesn't have to be there's no reason
for it to be and there are other
examples of consent handled very well
out there felon louise has a great scene
when it comes to that
frozen towards the very end i could kiss
you
i could i mean i'd like to i may i we me
i mean may we wait what
we may
[Music]
in children's media there's another
great metaphorical example in steven
universe with stevonnie the very first
time
that connie and steven fuse into that
character they are continually checking
in with each other are you okay
we can stop if you no
and that's not even an actual sex scene
it's just a metaphorical analogy for a
really close relationship but they're
still checking in continually
it's not
that hard
we're just not doing it
could we start
please
what are some of your favorite
depictions of consent in any media film
book
tv show video game because i know uh my
friend jesse gender likes to bring up
psychonauts too in regards to consent
because a big part of that game is
characters jumping into another
character's mind and in that particular
game they ask for permission before they
do it would you mind if i uh went inside
your mind and sorted a few things out
yeah i've never posted anything getting
properly sorted
so consent can take all kinds of forms
what are some of your favorite
depictions where do you think it was
done best
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it
like share subscribe they all help me
out if you really want to help me out
patreon
is what enables me to do this as my
living
and have these videos out on a regular
basis
at the
hopefully
quality that i'm able to do them
any amount you can provide is of great
assistance but even if you can't
it's okay
because what i really want you to
remember
is that you're beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you
are the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters immudelkey the oath the boy tt
for knobby lax the poodle zach paul
idoln tracey scrapbook vincent paul
bartolucci angry casper toku bl huvian
adam rdl taylor shane ross shaylee
gourley and brendan larose you want to
hear me mispronounce your name check out
rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
um
[Music]